criminal defense attorney and former DC
police detective Ted Williams and former
FBI special agent Manny Gomez
you know once again Ted we see what we
saw the police we saw the sheriff we saw
the FBI we see first responders you see
the everybody the superintendent the
governor the Attorney General everybody
really all hands on deck today and it's
days like today that you realize I was
watching this all unfold live on when I
was on my radio show today and just how
amazing these people are but they you
know it's after the fact
do we need to reconsider safety for
these schools well yeah I think we do
but let me say Shawn from the beginning
the interview you just had with those
two young women we saw the best of
America and those two young women and
when you look at this guy in Nicholas
Cruz you're seeing as the governor said
pure evil this was a cold blooded
calculated carried out carnage massacre
and we do have to start rethinking how
we have guards and security in these
various schools the sad commentary
though Sean is we cannot make our
schools of prison we did have a guard
there but if somebody is hell-bent on
going in a school and killing people and
killing young people 12 of these
beautiful young people are there tonight
this is a tragedy children in and of
itself
yeah this is not a political statement
and I know I'm known for talking
politics all the time this is not
political I don't think it is something
that most people would disagree with and
and Manuel throw those to you is that if
you're in any administrative building in
this case it's a school and it seems
that there's got to be greater order in
terms of monitoring who's getting into
this these schools
I know schools that monitor and control
who gets into them it can be done and it
can be done fairly easily but more
importantly and they did have a guard
what
I mean school this big that has 3200
students and multiple buildings it seems
to me you need a few people in each
building retired military retired police
and I would think over time that
families we're not talking about all
that much money at the end of the day if
each district you know is paying for
that security we have every building I
walk into in New York City every single
building if I'm not if I don't have an
ID I will go through security and if I
don't have a clearance I'm not getting
in and if we can do it in every building
in New York post 9/11 I would think we
could do it in every school in America
if we want to I totally agree with you
Sean and it's not controversial this is
it a gun debate no this has nothing to
do with guns this has to do with
protecting our children I totally agree
with you in terms of having formal
military and/or former law enforcement
one way to do it is to perhaps
federalize it after 9/11 we went from a
private security system in most airports
to TSA on their homeland secure great
example so that might be something that
Congress may want to consider and moving
forward set up a federal system to
protect our schools because some school
districts honestly don't have the budget
for it or may not be willing to raise
taxes for it even though it's a
necessary thing I don't at the end of
the day we got to put a price I remember
the movie years ago lean on me is about
the principal Joe Clark right and he got
in trouble because he he chained the the
school door shut that's not necessarily
the answer there should be very specific
entry points and other entry points
should be closed off and but beyond that
I think you need and look I don't even
know if it would have been applicable in
this situation but I've got to believe
in some situations that if you have
first-line defenders they're people that
are trained you know retired military
retired police that they're gonna be
able to at least hold off for the five
minutes the police got there the shara
got there they got there as fast as
humanly possible degree SWAT team was
there first responders were there
everyone did their job today right and
did it so well right but I'm just
thinking for the long-term we've got to
secure these schools again it's not
about guns it's secure the schools a
hundred percent both you guys I disagree
you it is about also about guns if you
put a security guardian with a pop gun
in one of these schools and you got a
guy coming in with an ar-15 rifle he
could even take that security guard and
somebody said I'm talking about armed
former military and armed former police
these are people we trust my guess would
be in most schools in most communities
those retired military retired police
would become the best friends of those
students over time they get to know each
other it would be good all the way
around for everybody
win-win safety security we can secure
anything we want to secure in this
country and nobody's going to convince
me otherwise I totally agree so going
back to former military former law
enforcement as an added benefit going
back to your win-win now you have
somebody who's been trained and if
there's other things going on in this
school visa be drugs bullying things
like that this is a trained professional
that can deal with that identify it
investigate it and deal with it so
that's an added benefit of having
somebody of that caliber there but it
has to be funded and it has to be a
serious conversation where we as a
nation say enough and we need to fund
this just perhaps like I mentioned the
TSA program right that last word for you
I'm I was not talking about unarmed
former retired military police said they
don't have to be showing their they
could obviously you know have it
concealed but they certainly would be
the front line of defense but I do
believe securing those doors nobody that
is expelled from the school should have
access to that school ever the other
thing is paying attention to mental
health issues or disgruntled kids or
disciplinary issues looking at this the
the social media footprint of of a kid
you can throw out of school apparently
we're learning from trace Gallagher we
could have learned a lot of
this kid and that happens after almost
every shooting people are telegraphing
where they're headed
well you're right you know or if you see
something you need to say something and
we don't have enough of that but I was
also happy I'm gonna saying I'm using
the word happy about what and encouraged
by what part Pam Bundy the Attorney
General said down there as it pertains
to the death penalty Sean when you take
a gas put gas mass on when you take
smoke guns bombs you go on to school you
pull all along you are able to shoot all
of these people and then you are able to
leave that school and I want to find out
that you're mentally ill I have a
serious problem with mental illness when
you have the colonies is incensed to
know how to do all of that
I know schools that have this security
and it works thank you both Manny Thank
You Ted thank you